Tri Alpha Energy, a company in California
has made a big advance in fusion energy.
Tri Alpha's machine is as long as two buses. It creates smoke rings of gas and then
slamms them together at nearly a
million km/h. This creates a hollow blob
of gas at around 10 million degrees
Celsius. In early experiments the gas
fell apart after just a couple of
thousands of a second.
But firing beams of high energy
particles helps keep it together.
This week the company announced that using more powerful angled beams
keeps the gas tube stable much longer.
Next, the team will build a bigger
even more powerful version to reach the
enormous temperatures needed for fusion.